Okay, so at this point we have
designed the experiments and now what?
And now it actually becomes easy.
Now that you have the experiments, you
need to run the test cases a number of
times using the [INAUDIBLE] ranges
of the experimental factors.
Compute the metrics,
the averages over of those n times and
then represent the results.
When it comes to representing
the results, I'm not going to go
into further discussion in terms of
best practices and how to do that.
But just keep in mind that the visual
representation can really help
strengthen your arguments.
And there are a lot of papers that will
be discussed during this course that use
different techniques on
how to represent results.
So you can draw some ideas from there.
Or there are other
documentations online,
there are also courses that
are taught at Georgia Tech or
also in the Audacity's platform that
talk about information visualization.
So you can benefit from such
content in terms of how
to really visualize your results.
And make sure that you don't
just show the results.
Actually make a conclusion, spell out
what is it that these experimental
results support as far as
your claims are concerned.